cette femme française pierre émile 58
ans ancien entre au couvent de cluny
avait quitté l'établissement scolaire le
2 décembre 2014 à midi au volant de son
véhicule
elle devait en principe reprendre l'écho
à 14 heures mais depuis aucune trace
aucun appel à ses proches
elle a disparu selon les premiers
éléments de l'enquète il semblerait
qu'elle a été aperçue pour la dernière
fois dans ce secteur au niveau de ses
distributeurs automatiques de billets
son véhicule avait été retrouvé le
lendemain le 3 décembre 2014
dans l'après-midi sur ce parking n'est
pas seul et unique mais aucune trace de
cette mère de famille
les techniciens en investigation
criminelle entre l'action et les couches
de traces du sang dans l'habitacle les
résultats des tests génétiques confirme
que le sang est bien celui de français
pierre émile débattus sont alors
organisés en plusieurs secteurs de l'île
les auditions des proches des français
affirment ils permettent de remonter à
la piste de phillip ponsard dans un
premier temps et nie les faits mais le
tout va se refermer des indices
confirment l'implication de ponça dans
ce dossier aujourd'hui il ya un faisceau
d'éléments et qui sont connues un
notamment les traces de sang retrouvées
dans la voiture elle est le fait que
monsieur ponsard qu'on soit allé chez
lui qu'il ait indiqué qu'on a retrouvé
des traces de sang chez lui le fait
qu'il ait passé cette maison à l'eau de
javel pour essayer d'enlever tous les
toutes les traces qui avait dans sa
maison et ça n'a pas réussi puisqu'on
sait aujourd'hui que techniquement on
peut retrouver mes marques et les mois
voire des années
les traces de sang quand il y en a vu
les ponts ça et placé en garde à vue
puis en détention provisoire au centre
pénitentiaire de ducos
finalement le 19 décembre 2014
sous les conseils de nouvel avocat
interrogé par le juge d'instruction
philippe pons a accepté de conduire les
enquêteurs sur la route de la trace en
direction du morne-rouge après 17 jours
le corps sans vie de français le père
émile est retrouvé en contrebas d'une
falaise
il est passé aux aveux ce matin il
aurait dit parce que je n'ai pas eu le
pv mais il aurait dit qu'il a il
reconnaît avoir effectivement donné la
mort à madame
pierre émile je n'ai pas encore les
conditions un je ne sais pas ce que dans
quelles conditions mais bon c'est
apparemment de ce qu'il aurait dit mais
bon ça c'est au conditionnel parce que
je n'ai pas encore le procès-verbal
voulait penser a finalement mis en
examen pour séquestration suivie de mort
mais des zones d'ombré planent encore
dans ce dossier quel est le mobile comme
enseignante qui a été aperçue pour la
dernière fois le 2 décembre dans ce
secteur a pu arriver au domicile de pont
sarah dj la terre suivi ou l'at-il ce
qu'est ce qu'est dès le départ
comment et où précisément at il perdu la
vie autant de questions qui restent en
suspens l'injure et les magistrats de la
cour d'assises tenteront de faire
jaillir la vérité
avant d'entrer en voie de condamnation
ce procès débute lentilles